[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون ويهد اقدم
لكم اخبار الساعه نبدا بالعناوين
اسرائيل تبحث رد على الهجوم بالصواريخ من
لبنان في غزه وتوقعات بشن هجوم الليله
مكروم في بكين للحديثه عن اوكرانيا
والرئيس الصيني ينصح اوروبا بان تظهر
استقلاليتها
البيت الابيض يقر باخطاء الانسحاب من
افغانستان ويحملها لاداره ترامب
ثلاث نساء محور محاكمه ترامب فهل يمنعنه
من الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم 34 صاروخا اطلقت من جنوب لبنان
باتجاه شمال اسرائيل في تصعيد جديد يضاف
الى التوترات اليوميه بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان
حماس هي التي اطلقت الصواريخ كما حمل
الحكومه اللبنانيه المسؤوليه لعدم منعها
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
اجتمعت الحكومه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
المصغره لمناقشه الرد وقال رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتانياهو ان اسرائيل ستواجه عدوها
وستجعله يدفع الثمن وقال نتنياهو ان
اسرائيل لا تسعى لتغيير الوضع الراهن في
الاماكن المقدسه مشيرا الى ان الخلافه
الداخلي لم يمنع اسرائيل من العمل ضد
اعدائها على حد وصفه هذا وقالت اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى انه سيتم شن هجوم
على غزه ولبنان الليله
سنعمل بقوه ضد المتطرفين الذين يلجاون
لاستخدام العنف ضدنا وبالنسبه للاستهداف
من الجهه الاخرى سنضرب اعدائنا وسيدفعون
ثمن عدوانيتهم وسيكتشفون كيف سيتوحد الشعب
الاسرائيلي بغض النظر عن كل الخلافات من
اجل الدفاع عن دولتنا وشعبنا
من جهتها اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
لاسرائيل الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها
ندين اطلاق الصواريخ من لبنان وغزه على
اسرائيل التزامنا بامن اسرائيل صارم
ونعترف بحقها المشروع في الدفاع عن نفسها
ضد جميع اشكال العدوان
[موسيقى]
يا جماعه عم يطلع الصواريخ من عنا شايفين
شايفين
[موسيقى]
الكل يترقب ماذا سيحصل الليله ما هي
المؤشرات على الارض
حاليا الاجتماع الحكومه الامنيه المصغره
في اوجه سيستمر عده ساعات التقديرات طبعا
بان القرار قد يكون ردا على الجغرافيتين
اللبنانيه بشكل محدود ربما واكثر ربما على
قطاع غزه كما قلنا منذ ساعات الظهر اتهام
باسرائيل الواضح لحماس جاء ليوضح بين
السطور بان الاستهداف الاساسي سيكون ربما
لقطاع غزه وايضا من الصواريخ انطلقت من
لبنان هذا يعني بان الرد سيكون ايضا في
لبنان رغم ان اسرائيل ستحاول ان لا تكون
اهداف تابعه لحزب الله بطبيعه الحال
لاحظتي بان نتنياهو تحدث بشكل عام لم يسمي
احدا لم يوجه اتهاما بالاسم لاي جهه
واطلق كلاما اطلق كلاما عاما فقط
بهذا المعنى لاعطاء ربما مساحه من
المناوره في الموضوع لكن التقديرات فعليا
بان لا تقدم اسرائيل في القصف اقل وهنا
على هذه الجبهة على جنوب لبنان ان لا تقدم
على استهداف اهداف تابعه لحزب الله كي لا
تشعل حربا ولا بنى تحتيه تابعه للدوله
اللبنانيه لان ذلك قد يتطلب ردا ايضا
وبالتالي قد تكون هناك قصف لمناطق فارغه
في لبنان من قبل الاسرائيليين زياد بينما
انت معنا ايضا توجد مواجهات بين القوات
الاسرائيليه وفلسطينيين في الناصره وام
الفحم نتابع هذه الصور
[موسيقى]
اعود اليك زياده طبعا هذا التصعيد اليوم
يستكمل التصعيد في الايام الماضيه بموضوع
اقتحام المسجد الاقصى وكنا تابعنا مواجهات
في المسجد الاقصى في الايام الماضيه ويبدو
بان هذه المواجهات ما زالت مستمره ولكن
اذا اردنا ان نبقى على موضوع الصواريخ
التي اطلقت اليوم من لبنان على اسرائيل من
خلال البيانات التي اصدرتها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه حتى الان والمواقف حتى الان
التصعيد سيكون اذا حدث سيكون محدودا خاصه
بانه هناك وضع داخلي في اسرائيل لا يسمح
يبدو ان توسع الجبهات
هذا صحيح يؤخذ في الاعتبار بطبيعه الحال
طبعا لا يستطيع احد ان يجزم بما ستكون
عليه طبيعه الرد ان كان حجم هذا الرد وما
الى ذلك وعاده لا يتم التحكم في الردود
على الارض بمعنى نتائج اي عمل عسكري تكون
محسوبه عاده ولكن هناك حسابات خاطئه وهناك
نتائج خاطئه لاعمال عسكريه قد تشعل
الموضوع برمته هذا ايضا يؤخذ في الحسبان
لكن
دعينا نقول الانطباع العام في هذه الليله
بان الردود قد تكون محدوده ليس من باب
المصادفه اي ابدا ان ينتظر الجيش
الاسرائيلي بيانا يتهم حماس يقول انها
المتهم المركزي على حد وصفه في البيان في
عمليه اطلاق الصواريخ من لبنان ويذكر في
البيان ذاته بان حماس اطلقت بالامس صواريخ
على باتجاه اسرائيل كانت طبعا صواريخ ارض
جو وليست صواريخ استهداف ولكن ايا كان ليس
من باب المصادفه ان يذكر الامران معا في
بيان واحد هذا قد يدلل على ما نتحدث به
منذ ساعات الظهيره بان الرد قد يكون في
قطاع غزه وايضا في جنوب لبنان
كي يعني نشير الى ما اقوله بان هناك دائما
الخوف من الحسابات الخاطئه جرى فتح
الملاجئ في بحيره تل ابيب هذه الليله
بمعنى ان هناك في اسرائيل ايضا من قد من
قد يعتبر بان الامور قد تصل الى امر اشمل
واكبر وابعد مدد زياد في نشره سابقه كن
ذكرت لي عن هذه الحكومه الامنيه بانه ليس
لديها لديها اي تجارب امنيه بهذا الاطار
هل يمكن ان نتخوف بان تكون قراراتها غير
محسوبه النتائج
بطبيعه الحال نتنياهو لديه تجربه ووزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي وهو جنرال لديه تجربه
ولكن معظم بالفعل من هم الان على الطاوله
ليس لديهم ادنى فكره عن المواضيع الامنيه
بنجفير لم يخدم يوما واحدا في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وكذا ايضا سموتريج
وبالتالي كلاهما لديه صوت يستطيع ان يصوت
لصالح عمليه او ضد العمليه التي قد تحدث
هذه الليله ولكن اعتقد ما سيكون الفيصل في
الموضوع هو موقف الجيش الاسرائيلي
والاجهزه الامنيه حاليا ما يرشح عن هذا
الاجتماع هو ان التوجه الى رد ولكن قد
يكون ردا ليس كاسرا لقواعد اللعبه دعينا
نقول للتذكير يمكن لاسرائيل ان تقصف مناطق
مفتوحه في لبنان وان تقصف قطاع غزه وان
ترد على حزب الله على فكره في الجغرافيا
السوريه هذا ايضا ليس مستبعدا ذلك ملعب
مريح للطرفين عاده
الضربات التي يتبادلها حزب الله واسرائيل
اساسا هي في الجغرافيا السوريه شكرا لك
حتى الان مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي
دائما سنبقي اعيننا على ما يحدث من تطورات
الليله وسنكون معك دائما
[موسيقى]
خلال زياره الرئيس الفرنسي ايمنويل ماكرون
الى الصين دعا الرئيسان الصيني والفرنسي
الى محادثات روسيه اوكرانيه في اقرب وقت
ممكن واشدد الرئيس الصيني على اهميه
التزام جميع دول العالم باتفاقيه حظر
انتشار النووي وتجنب تصعيد الصراعات واكد
تشيد
تعتبر اوروبا قطبا مستقلا وتدعم
استقلاليته الاستراتيجيه
جميع الاطراف على الوفاء بالوعود المتعلقه
بعدم استخدام الاسلحه النوويه ومعارضه
استخدام الاسلحه البيولوجيه والكيميائيه
تحت اي ظرف من الظروف ومعارضه الهجوم
المسلح على المنشات النوويه المدنيه مثل
محطات الطاقه النوويه كما يجب استئناف
محادثات السلام في اقرب وقت ممكن
ان الرئيس الصيني ابلغه انه سيتحدث الى
نظيره الاوكراني كما قال ان حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا انهت عقودا من السلام في اوروبا
من الواضح ان الحديث عن الامن والاستقرار
عن الحديث عن الحرب التي تشنها روسيا على
اوكرانيا هذه الحرب انهت عقودا من السلام
على الاراضي الاوروبيه لكنها حرب الجميع
لان احد اعضاء الانف الامم المتحده انتهك
الميثاق وهذا غير مقبول
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد لحظات اتفاق
سعودي ايراني على بدء ترتيبات اعاده فتح
السفارتين والقنصليات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وقعت السعوديه وايران
بيان المشتركا عقب لقائي وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان والايراني
حسين امير عبداللهيان في العاصمه الصينيه
وجاء في البيان المشترك انه تم الاتفاق
على بدء ترتيبات اعاده فتح السفرتين
والقنصليات وكذلك بحث استئناف الرحلات
الجويه وتسهيل منح التاشيرات للمواطنين
كما تم الاتفاق على بحث استئناف تبادل
زيارات المسؤولين ووفود القطاع الخاص
ودعاء وزير الخارجيه السعودي نظيره
الايراني لزياره الرياض وعقد لقاء ثنائي
واكد القيامه بكل ما يلزم لتحقيق امنه
واستقرار المنطقه
[موسيقى]
والان الى الشان الامريكي خبايا انسحاب
الجيش الامريكي من افغانستان لا تزال
تتكشف مع الوقت بعد مرور عام ونصف على
الانسحاب سلم البيت الابيض تقريرا سريا
للكونجرس يكشف تفاصيل الانسحاب التي لا
تخلو من اتهامات تطالب اداره الرئيس
السابق
فنتائج المراجعات لقرار الانسحاب حملت
مسؤوليه النهايه الماساويه والتداعياتها
لاداره ترامب والى خطتها البيت الابيض نفع
امكانيه فعل شيء لتغيير مسار الانسحاب في
اشاره الى ان الانسحاب كان امرا واقعا ولن
يمنع سيطره طالبان حتى لو تم الابقاء على
2500 جنديا في قاعده باجرام حاطه البيت
الابيض بملف افغانستان اتهمت ترامب بوضع
تاريخ للانسحاب من افغانستان من دون خطه
اولا لقد كان قرار الرئيس بانهاء الحرب في
افغانستان
خيارات الرئيس بايدن لكيفيه تنفيذ
الانسحاب كانت مقيده بشده بسبب الظروف
التي خلقها سلفه دونالد ترامب الذي وضع
تاريخا للانسحاب من دون خطه اداره ترامب
لم تسلم تقارير عن الوضع في افغانستان عند
تسلم بيض السلطه لا شيء كان يمكن ان يغير
تلك النهايه الماساويه حتى لو تم الابقاء
على 2500 جندي فذلك لن يمنع سيطره طالبان
قرار الانسحاب من افغانستان لم يضعف
امريكا دوليا لقد سلمنا الكونغرس نتائج
تقرير مراجعه قرار الانسحاب لمناقشته
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه ليطلعنا على
تفاصيل هذه المراجعه اتجاه افغانستان
وماذا في تفاصيل ما تحدث عنه البيت الابيض
اليوم
اعتقد انك ذكرتي العناصر الاساسيه من هذا
التقرير ميسون ما يجب اضافته هو ان جون
كيربي وايضا التقرير الذي تم توزيعه اليوم
على الامريكيين والصحفيين يشير الى ان
اداره بيضا تعتمد الان استراتيجيه ما وراء
الافق وتعتبر ان هذه هي الاستراتيجيه هي
استراتيجيه ناجحه حاول طبعا جونكوربي قدر
المستطاع ان يلقي اللوم على الاداره
السابقه اداره ترامب فيما عقدته من
توافقات لم نقل اتفاقيات مع تنظيم طالبان
واشار الى ان اعضاء الحكومه الامريكيه في
ظل بايدن قاموا جميعا باعمالهم كما يجب
العنصر الاساسي الغائب هو هل صحيح ان
مقالته اداره بيدنا عن اتفاقيات ترامب مع
طالبان هي صحيحه ام لا بالنسبه لهذا
التقرير عندما
يقدم هل
بناء اي شيء على نتائجه هل تتخذ اي
اجراءات عند تقييم هذا التقرير
سئل المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي اكثر
من مره هل هناك اي شخص سوف يتحمل مسؤوليه
الاخطاء والارواح التي فقدت في افغانستان
خصوصا عندما صار الهجوم الانتحاري على
المطار في كابول الجواب كان عمليا هو لا
حاول بمحاضره كربيان يقول ان كل الاشخاص
الذين قاموا باعمالهم في ظل بيض قاموا
باعمالهم بما هو مطلوب هذا ليس رايي
الجمهوريين طبعا الجمهوريون في مجلس
النواب الامريكي يقومون بعمليه تحقيق في
هذه القضيه ويريدون وثائق اكثر من اداره
بيض وهم مصممون على كشف المزيد من الحقائق
وتحميل اداره بايدن مسؤوليه ما حدث في
كابول شكرا لك
على كل هذه التوضيحات كنت معي من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
ونذكر مشاهدينا بان القوات الاسرائيليه
تقتحم واباحات المسجد الاقصى لليوم الثالث
على التوالي كنا تابعنا مواجهات حصلت
بالامس وقبل امس لاقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه للمسجد الاقصى خلال صلاه بعض
المصلين هناك وبعض المعتكفين ويبدو بانه
هذه هذا الاقتحام ايضا يتجدد لليوم الثالث
على التوالي نتابع هذه الصور من امام
المسجد الاقصى كانت هذه الصور قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الان الى فرنسا حيث كان هناك يوم عاصف
جديد احتجاجا على قانون رفع سن التقاعد
الذي يتمسك به الرئيس الفرنسي
الاحتجاجات التي بدات هادئه في مناطق
مختلفه في فرنسا سرعان ما تحولت الى
اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين ورجال الامن هذا
واعلنت النقبات الفرنسيه ان اكثر من
مليوني شخصا شاركوا في الاحتياجات اليوم
كما اعلنوا عن يوم احتياجات جديد في
الثالثه عشر من ابريل
الاحتجاجات اتخذت طابعا شخصيا للغايه حيث
اتجه المتظاهرون الى حرق المطعم المفضل
للرئيس الفرنسي امام المكروه في العاصمه
[موسيقى]
والى قضيه الرئيس الامريكي السابق استدعى
الجمهوريون بمجلس النواب مدعيا عاما سابقا
في ساهم في اطلاق قضيه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامب وتم استدعاء ماركه وهو احد
كبار المدعين العامين في منهات الذين
حققوا مع الرئيس الامريكي السابق وكان
جزءا من محاولات مكتب المدعي العام في
منهاتن لرفع دعوى ضد ترامب لكنه استقال في
فبراير 20 22
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يواجه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب مشاكل قد تهدد نفوذه وتطيح باماله
في العوده كرئيس عام 2024 بسبب علاقات
غراميه نسبت اليه قبل توليه الرئاسه نتابع
لكنهن قد يطحنا بعرش واحد من اقوى رجال
العالم في لحظه ترامب في مازق مع قصصه
الغراميه السابقه
نجمه مجله
تقول انها تلقت 150 الف دولار مقابل صمتها
عن علاقه غراميه
خرجت ستورمي دانيالز لتدعي انها تلقت 130
الف دولار لاخفاء علاقه جنسيه بترامب فهل
صحيح ان ترامب كان زيرا نساء ولديه الكثير
من القصص هذا ما تحقق فيه المحكمه وما قد
يحدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي
لم افكر ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث
في امريكا ولم اعتقد ابدا انه يمكن ان
يحدث الجريمه الوحيده التي ارتكبتها هي
الدفاع بلا خوف عن امتنا من اولئك الذين
يسعون الى تدميرها منذ البدايه تجسست
الديمقراطيون على حملته تذكر ذلك لقد
هاجموني بتهم من التحقيقات الاحتياليه
زوجه ترامب عارضه الازياء السابقه ميلانيا
لا يبدو انها سعيده بقصص زوجها مع النساء
وان كانت غير مشبته في المحكمه حتى اللحظه
غيرتها وربما اشياء اخرى دفعتها للاختفاء
عن الاضواء وعدم الظهور بجانب زوجها في
محنته الحاليه
وحدها البنت سر ابيها اذا كان ابنه ترامب
المدلله تواصل الدفاع عن والدها وتنفي عنه
عده تهم منها التحرش الجنسي يواجه ترامب
34 تهمه نفاها كلها في محكمه نيويورك منها
تهم فساد ومنها تهم احتيال ونساء قد يكون
كيدهن سببا في وضع اقوى رجال العالم خلف
القضبان
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل بعد
شهرين من الزلزال سكانه انطاكيا متشككون
في وعد الحكومه باعاده الاعمار خلال عام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه مع
اتصال في شهر رمضان يدخل موسم العمره
مرحله اخرى نظرا لتزايد اعداد المعتمرين
والزوار ما دعى لايجاد خدمات اسعافيه
طارئه عبر استحداث فرق الدراجات الناريه
التابعه للهلال الاحمر السعودي سلسله من
الحرمين
[موسيقى]
موسى عسيري يعمل كاختصاص خدمات طبيه طارئه
يمتطي دراجته الهوائيه بمكه لتقديم
الاسعافات الاوليه للمعتمرين والمصلين في
المواقع التي يصعب على مركبات الاسعاف
الوصول اليها الان في المنطقه المركزيه
بالدراجه الهوائيه في معدل 5 الى 6 دقايق
من موقعنا الى موقع الحاله خدمتي فيها
الهلال الاحمر تسع سنوات بالنسبه للحالات
اللي نباشرها الان بالدراجه الهوائيه
متراوحه ما بين اعياء اجهاد حراري بسيطه
من الحالات اللي ما انساها باشرنا حاله
وصلنا الحاج بفندق
كان بيتحدث معانا فجاه
توقف القلب والتنفس عملنا له انعاش قلبي
ريااوي والحمد لله يعني عاد النبض والتنفس
في المستشفى استحدثت هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي بموسم العمره فرقات دراجات
الهوائيه في المنطقه المركزيه لضمان سرعه
الوصول الى الحالات الطارئه في اوقات
الذروه اذ يتعامل المسعفون مع خمسين حاله
يوميه هذه الدرجات تعمل بماطور كهربائي
يوفر الوقت والجهد والماطور يعمل بسرعه من
20 الى 30 كيلومتر في الساعه بقوه تحمل
تصل الى 90 كيلو متر الشحن الواحده مجهزه
تجهيز كامل بحيث يقدم لطالب الخدمه
الاسعافيه جميع الخدمات التي يحتاجها وفي
حال احتياجه لسياره اسعاف يتم دعمهم
بسياره الاسعاف في ابقاء الفرقه لحال اصول
العمر منظومه صحيه كبرى عملت عليها الجهه
المعنيه في السعوديه بموسم
في ظل ازدياد الاعداد الملحوظ للمعتمرين
والمصلين والذي يصل الى اكثر من مليون
و200 الف زائرين يوميا للحرم المكي من مكه
المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
اسامه قاسم اسامه اهلا بك معنا اخر
الاحصائيات والارقام
للزوار والمعتمرين
اهلا وسهلا ميسون تحيه طيبه لكم للجميع
مشاهدي قناه العربيه انقل لكم الصوت
والصور اليوم من امام المطاف الاول
وبالتالي امامنا صحن المطاف الذي يشهد
الان امتلاء كبيرا اترك لكم الصوره الان
لتشاهدوا امتلاء صحن المطاف طبعا اتحدث
اليوم عن ارقام كبيره جدا على مستوى
الخدمه التشغيليه على مستوى الخطه
الموجوده اليوم لهذه الايام والعن بدا
الخطه التشغيليه الثانيه اتحدث اليوم ايضا
عن اعداد الزوار المعتمرين الذين وصلوا
الى قرابه 14 مليون زائرا ومعتمر منذ
بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك نلحظ الان امتلاء
صحن المطاف الذي يشهد اليوم ازدحاما كبيرا
جدا لنا تقريبا ساعه من بعد انتهاء صلاه
التراويح في الحرم المكي الذي نشهد الان
ايضا امتلاء المداخل والمخارج وهذا ما
يعني انسيابيه الحركه في الدخول والخروج
الى المطاف طبعا نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
المطاف الاول مطاف الثاني والثالث والرابع
هم الان امامكم بالصوره ممتلئين بالكامل
وبالتاكيد انه انسيابيه الحركه جاءت ضمن
خطه تشغيليه اعلنت عنها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين من بدايه العشره الثانيه طبعا
الرئاسه اعلنت في بيان سابق لها عن نجاح
الخطه التشغيليه الاولى التي شملت العشره
ايام اولا ثم من بدءها بالخطه تشغيليه
الثانيه التي تنتهي في نهايه العشره
الثانيه ثم بدا الخط التشغيليه الثالثه
الاكبر وهي خطه العشر الاواخر طبعا
الخدمات المقدمه ايضا اليوم التي نتحدث
عنها تقديم اكثر من 30 مليون لتر مياه
سقيا زمزم هنا في جنبات المسجد الحرام
نتحدث ايضا عن الخدمات الانسانيه الطبيه
الاجتماعيه وحتى خدمات الترجمه من قبل
المترجمين موزعين على ابواب وساحات المسجد
الحرام طبعا في ايضا هناك عدد من
الفعاليات والبرامج سوف تقام في الايام
القادمه منها تاتشين عدد من الاجهزه اجهزه
الروبوت التي تترجم للزوار والمعتمرين
باغلب اللغات وستتواجد بحول الله تعالى
على مداخل ومخارج صحن المطاف نتحدث ايضا
وامامنا صحن المطاف ممتلئ بالكامل الذي
يشهد اليوم حضور كبير جدا من الزوار
والمعتمرين ميسون يتحدث ايضا عن الخدمات
الاخرى كخدمات الهلال الاحمر الذين وصلوا
الى اكثر من سبعه الاف مستفيده ومستفيده
من خدمات الخدمات الصحيه لهلال الاحمر
نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن خدمه المعارض
الموجوده اليوم في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن تهيئه
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بالكامل بما
فيها بادوارها وساحاتها وايضا شكرا
لاستقبال المصلين اشكرك على هذه
التي اعطيتنا اياها بكل ما يجري الان في
مكه المكرمه شكرا لك مراسل العربيه اسامه
قاسم
في مدينه انطاكيا التركيه تعمل الجرافات
على تسويه المباني المنهاره بفعل الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب البلاد في السياق عبر بعض
سكان المدينه عن حزنهم على محل بهم جراء
الزلزال فيما شكك اخرنا في تعهد الحكومه
بخطه اعاده بناء المدينه خلال عام بدوره
اكد مدير مشروع اعاده البناء ان العديد من
المباني لا تزال مهدده بالانهيار وتشكل
خطرا كبيرا
ارى مره اخيره منزل المدمر الذي بنيت فيه
حياتي كان لدي امل في العثور على تذكار
للاحتفاظ به لكن العمال بشروا بازاله
الركام ولم يعد ذلك ممكنا
لا اعتقد انه يمكن انجاز اعاده الاعمار في
غضون عام على الاقل هنا ولكن في ظل هذه
الظروف ستستغرق ازاله الانقاض وحدها عاما
على الاقل
المباني التي على وشك الانهيار هي المباني
التي تشكل خطرا
بعد يوم من نقله الى عنايه المركزه بسبب
الصعوبات في التنفس اعلن الاطباء ان
الرئيس الوزراء الايطالي السابق سلبي مصاب
بسرطان الدم واكد الاطباء ان حاله
برلسكوني تحسنت عن الامس فيما يواصل تلقي
العلاج في وحده للقلب بعيني المركزه في
مستشفى بميلانو
بهوتافات ليس ملكي استقبل المتظاهرون
الملك تشارلز الثالث والملكه القرينه
كامله عند وصولهم الى كاتدرائيه يويورك
وفي اول خدمته في خميس العهد كملك سيقدم
تشارلز عملات تذكاريه تحتفل بعيد ميلاده
الخامس والسبعين ومن المقرر ان يتم
التتويج الرسمي لتشيلسي في السادس من مايو
احتفالا بذكرى وفاته الخمسين فنان في شمال
ايطاليا جعل من ارضه لوحه لرسم صوره
للفنان بابلو بيكاسو حيث استخدم جرارا
ومحراثا واداه دواره لتحويل حقل مساحته 25
الف متر مربع الى صوره
[موسيقى]
نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
اسرائيل تبحث الرد على الهجوم بالصواريخ
من لبنان في غزه وتوقعاتهم بشن هجوم
الليله
مكروم في بكين الحديث عن اوكرانيا والرئيس
الصيني ينصح اوروبا بان تظهر استقلاليتها
البيت الابيض يقر باخطاء الانسحاب من
افغانستان ويحملها لاداره ترامب
ثلاث نساء محور محاكمه ترامب فهل يمنعنه
من الترشح الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه اترككم في امان
الله
[موسيقى]